con las buenas noches bueno lo primero
que vemos completamente es que lo que
hay es una tensión entre un gobierno
subnacional que es un gobierno que ha
sido muy importante en la historia
reciente de etiopía tanto en la guerra
con el vecino eritrea como la liberación
del país de la junta comunista y lo que
vemos concretamente es un pulso entre
ese gobierno central de addis abeba y la
región del tigre y obviamente lo que
vemos es una posición enérgica del
primer ministro etíope porque pues lo
que está en juego es la unidad de
etiopía y lo que yo siente concretamente
es que no necesitan digamos como ningún
permiso de la comunidad internacional
para normalizar la situación en este en
este estado que cada vez ha pedido más
autonomía y por otro lado tenemos puesto
enorme inquietud por la crisis
humanitaria que puede desatar las
intervenciones militares o la operación
militar que está llevando a cabo el
presidente ahmed ali y que puede tener
efectos sobre sudán y sobre eritrea
precisamente se estima que más de 43 mil
refugiados han huido a sudan estamos
hablando de una nueva
gran crisis humanitaria que ahora afecta
a áfrica
sin duda alguna y yo le recordaría a la
gente que esta es una zona que viene
golpeada por dos coyunturas muy muy
críticas en primer lugar hace unos diez
o doce años estábamos hablando del
genocidio en darfur que provocó lo que
era en ese momento la peor crisis de
refugiados que tuvo el mundo y que ya
había impactado la zona tenemos además
de eso la salida constante de personas
que huyen del régimen de cea y hasta
farc y en eritrea y además esta es una
zona que colinda con el sahel en donde
recientemente ha habido ataques de
grupos de terroristas de fundamentalismo
islámico entonces es muy grave que ahora
a esa coyuntura crítica de los últimos
años se sume una crisis en uno de los
países más estables del cuerno africano
como como no era etiopía yo creo que ni
ciudad
ni somalia ni egipto ni en general los
países circundantes a donde podrían
llegar los refugiados eritreos están
preparados para la salida hasta ahora de
40 mil personas pero cuyo número se
puede disparar en las siguientes semanas
usted mencionaba ahora como este
conflicto puede afectar a varios países
vecinos pero cómo puede afectar no sólo
a la región sino al continente
pues en términos generales no puede
afectar en dos sentidos en el primer
sentido insisto porque aquí tenemos un
flujo de personas de inmigrantes en
situación muy difícil decir desde que
libia es básicamente un caos total
después de la caída de gadafi lo que se
ha producido la llegada de muchos grupos
terroristas que han azotado toda la zona
de israel hasta cierto punto del cuerno
africano entonces de nuevo la salida
masiva de personas en condiciones
difíciles pues crean una crisis en
segundo lugar hay un enfrentamiento con
eritrea porque se presume que eritrea
está apoyando a etiopía en esta guerra
contra los rebeldes en el tigre ahí hay
una digamos una animadversión histórica
entre el freeware y los rebeldes del
frente popular de liberación de tigre y
en tercer lugar insisto porque pues si
hay terceros estados que eventualmente
puedan o apoyar a etiopía o apoyar a los
rebeldes pues estaríamos con un
conflicto que puede hacer un eco un eco
regional